hey chess equals hey char is a
moderately crazy game of Thrones theory
claiming that the current pace septum is
actually Howland Reed
so Howland Reed is the lord of greywater
watch in the neck a region full of
swamps and bogs and inhabited by people
called the crannogmen the actual castle
of greywater watch is built on an
artificial island that floats around the
neck what you could call Howl's Moving
Castle Howland is the father of Meera
and Jojen Reed the siblings that bran is
travelling with and back in the day
Howland was a close friend of Eddard
Stark they fought together in Robert's
rebellion and Ned says Howland saved his
life at the Tower of joy in fact Howland
is now the last survivor of the fight of
the Tower of joy and so is as far as we
know the last person alive who knows
that John is the son of Rhaegar and
Lyanna but despite all this Howland
hypeeee Lord Reed hasn't done anything
in the story so far
Robb speaks of the worth of Howland Reed
and sentence and letters during the war
but none of it results in action george
RR martin has said that Howland will
appear eventually so the question is
when and how the High Septon is the
leader of the faith of the seven the
dominant religion in Westeros the High
Septon is usually elected by a Council
of high ranking clergy at which point
they stop using their old name start
wearing a funny hat and are considered
God's voice on earth so basically the
Pope since high septons don't use
individual names it can be hard to tell
them apart but in the song so far we've
seen three the fat one who was killed in
the riot of King's Landing then a
replacement who was installed by Tyrion
and murdered by oz Nieto black for
Cersei and then the third High Septon
who is really something different rather
than being installed as a pawn of
nobility he was swept into power on the
shoulders of a popular religious
movement of common people who call
themselves sparrows the sparrows are
outraged by the disruption and horror
caused by the wars of squabbling kings
especially that inflicted on the people
of the faith they're angry with the
nobility and especially the crowd who
have abandoned them so unlike the last
couple of high septons this so-called
high Sparrow seems to actually be deeply
devout and he advocates the interests of
the faith and the common people in ways
that his predecessors did not so H s
equals HR claims that this new High
Septon the high Sparrow is actually
secretly Howland Reed the obvious
question here is why Lord Reed would
want
be high septon one reason is that being
high septon would allow him to strike
back at the people who destroyed the
Starks the crannogmen are known to be
stout allies of the Starks and Howland
would be particularly outraged by the
killing of his friend Ned indeed the
high Sparrow brings up at odds execution
to Cersei condemning the killing with
strong words though any bloodshed on the
steps of us helped would likely upset
the High Septon in any case Howland may
be using the position of High Septon to
gain power and take vengeance the high
Sparrow does gain a great deal of power
he successfully negotiates for the
reinstatement of the two military orders
of the faith
the Warriors sons and the poor fellows
collectively referred to as the faith
militant the high Sparrow was willing to
trade away almost a million gold pieces
owed to the faith in order to achieve
this which does suggest a preference for
short-term power rather than the long
term pediment of the face
the high Sparrow goes on to arrest
Margaery Tyrell and tour Charlie kettle
black then has Cersei imprisoned and
sent on a politically and emotionally
crushing walk of shame he also refuses
to anoint Tommen an important ritual for
the boy Kings legitimization so the high
Sparrow has already inflicted a lot of
damage to the Lannister regime but he
could do much more it's hard to
overstate how powerful the high Sparrow
is becoming everyone from hedge Knights
to small folk - Lancel Lannister are
signing up to fight for him in the heart
of King's Landing at a time when the
crown is weak and unstable Tywin and
Kevin are dead most of the Lannister
soldiers are off with Jaime the King's a
boy the small Council is incompetent
Cersei is imploding and the masses of
rising at the sparrows command we don't
yet know what the high Sparrow will do
with all that power but if he is Howland
Reed the next steps could well be
finishing off the Lannisters perhaps
even taking control of King's Landing in
the Iron Throne
it might also involve revealing to
Westeros the secret of Jon Snow's
parentage as the son of Rhaegar
Targaryen John could conceivably make a
claim on the Iron Throne especially if
the Lannisters aroused it beforehand
that is of course a big claim which to
be realized would require the support of
someone very influential the high
Sparrow could be that someone he
increasingly holds the hearts and minds
of the common people of Westeros and has
kings and High Lords dancing to his
twittering Howland Reed as High Septon
would be perfectly placed to spread word
of and support for Jon
claim so what actual evidence do we have
that Howland Reed and the high Sparrow
are the same person one thing is that
the high sparrows appearance matches
that of the reeds and of the crannogmen
generally the high Sparrow is described
as short and thin with hair tied in a
knot behind his head Holland's children
are described with striking similarity
Mira is slim with hair knotted behind
her head and both Reed's are slight of
build slender and scarcely taller than
bran the high Sparrow looks like a reed
further the high Sparrow has eyes as
brown as mud and is said to have been
born with filth beneath his fingernails
alluding to the mud that's associated
with chronic man who little Walder Frey
calls mud men
further chronic men are known to use
sneaky tactics bran says they prefer to
hide from foes rather than face them in
open battle little Walder Frey calls
them sneaks and says you never see them
that they see you the world of Ice and
Fire says they're small sly and
secretive all of this stuff seems very
consistent with the tactic of
infiltration to indirectly attack
enemies and reveal secrets also
crannogmen seemed to be connected to
greensight and other magical powers the
world of Ice and Fire suggests the
crannogmen were close to the children of
the forest and might have even
intermarried with them which could
explain their small stature as well as
the green eyes and green sight that we
see in dojin
if the chronic men have magical insight
they may as maester Luwin suggests have
secret knowledge when Meera and Jojen
swear gray water watched at Winterfell
they use an unusual oath swearing by Ice
and Fire
which alludes to Jon Stark and Targaryen
blood so maybe the reeds perhaps through
a Georgian know about Jon's importance
as the prince that was promised or a
head of the dragon with three heads or
azor Ahai or whatever prophecy you want
to use to indicate these great magical
importance it's unclear how this could
connect to Jojen and brandon the
three-eyed raven but it seems possible
that Howland Reed knows something about
Jon's significance which may motivate
his ploy to play high Sparrow and one
very quick last thing is this quote from
Varys power sneaky [ __ ] small man and
large shadow but yet moving on so there
is some evidence if vague evidence for
HS equals a char but there are also
problems first is Howland's absence from
the neck
the high Sparrow has been spending a
great deal of time walking
Westeros gathering support building up
the movement of sparrows if Howland has
been absent from his home all this time
who's leading his people in this time of
law his kids have wandered off beyond
the wall and could be dead for all he
knows his wife Diana or is presumably
still at greywater governing perhaps but
we really know nothing about her things
are only getting crazier up north with
Baratheon's Bolton's iron men Klansmen
wildlings others surely Howland couldn't
abandon his family and people at a time
like this another problem is that of a
Northman becoming High Septon in the
north people follow the old gods not the
seven and the closeness of the
crannogmen to the children of the forest
and the magic of the old gods further
separates them from the new faith the
high Sparrow surely has demonstrated a
deep religiosity and knowledge of the
faith he says he tendered a half a
hundred little villages performing
marriages absolving sinners of their
sins
naming newborn children how could a
Northman someone from an extremely
different culture convincingly perform
all this religious service let alone
become the ultimate religious leader of
the faith Howland being High Septon is
like a Buddhist becoming Pope or a Jew
becoming an imam it's conceivable that
Howland has studied the faith of the
seven nor follows it even secretly I
guess but it's all very implausible
ultimately the biggest problem with H s
equals HR is that it doesn't make sense
as a plan for the theory to be true
Howland must have sat down one day
during the war with winter coming and
decided that the best plan of action was
for him to go wander the Riverlands on
foot performing religious service for a
foreign religion until he manages to
become the leader of a popular uprising
and then become the High Septon a
position with power sufficient to strike
at the crown all support Jon Snow all
the while hiding his identity and faking
faith like seriously and the plan relies
not only on a popular movement that Alan
surely couldn't have predicted or
single-handedly created but also on a
degree of political instability that not
even Littlefinger accurately predicted
it would make far more sense for Howland
to stay in the north that way he could
protect his family and homeland from the
increasingly bloody war in the north and
strike against the Bolton's who betrayed
robb and perpetrated the red wedding he
might not be able to support John's
claim on the throne but he could support
John's claim on the north in a Catelyn
chapter of a Storm of Swords Rob names
John his heir as King in the north
right after Robson's major Mormont and
galbart Glover with a letter to Howland
Reed
so assuming they made it Howland
probably knows that John is there to the
north as well as the son of Rhaegar it
may be that he's been working with major
and Gilbert ever since which would
explain where the three have been all
this time staying in the north wouldn't
help Allen strike at King's Landing but
would a reclusive crannogmen really
prioritize attacking a distant capital
over protecting his home the only real
disadvantage to staying in the north is
that it couldn't allow Howland to
dramatically reveal R plus L equals J to
the realm but george RR martin is
already setting up for that revelation
to happen in a very different way john's
parentage is probably going to be
revealed with brands magical powers in a
dance with dragons bran has visions of
past events that happened in front of
weirwood trees now we know that northern
marriage customs involve a ceremony in
front of a weirwood tree and we know
that just before the rebellion Rhaegar
and Lyanna were at or at least very near
the Isle of faces which is the site of
the only weirwood Grove south of the
neck and which has been named by George
our Martin as some way that will come to
the fore in later books George our
Martin is setting up for bran to have a
vision of Rhaegar and Lyanna secret
marriage at the Isle of faces which
presumably would lead to a revelation of
John's parentage
it's almost foreshadowed by brands
unwitting discovery of Cersei and
Jaime's incest he saw a relationship
that he wasn't supposed to with big
implications for the parentage of the
star-crossed lovers children so we don't
need some complicated and implausible
contrivance to reveal a plus L equals J
brands visions are already about to do
it admittedly while brands visions could
reveal R plus L equals J to bran and
maybe to John it would take something
more for everyone else in Westeros to
find out if John was to make a claim on
the throne as a Targaryen he would need
more than the word of a tree boy to back
him up and as suggested before
Howland Reed as high Sparrow would
people placed to do that
so HS equals a child doesn't have any
strong evidence and is pretty
implausible in a bunch of ways there are
some tantalizing facts that kind of back
it up but all those facts are still
compatible with the simpler explanation
that Howland is still in the north and
that the high Sparrow is just what he
seems so HS equals H R is a cool theory
but it's probably not true
thanks for watching subscribe if you
want to see more
you